President Biden out west on a mission to
save the planet from climate Armageddon
Joe touting his efforts to fight climate
change during a three-day field trip it
looks like he got the senior discount on
the Grand Canyon tour the president
appearing to get lost in the bushes and
his thoughts
Grand Canyon one of the Earth's nine
wonders wonders of the world
literally
think of that there's a you know it's
amazing an enduring symbol of America
for the entire world
it's a wonder he's president it's seven
natural wonders of the world Mr
President eventually Gramps found his
way to a TV Camera sitting down with the
weather channel to Ramble On more about
global warming and even provide some
quality Pest Control
are you prepared to declare a national
emergency with respect to climate
climate I've already done that
national bird we've conserved more land
we've moved into it we've rejoined the
Paris climate Accord we've passed the
368 billion dollar climate control
facility we we're moving is the is the
existential threat to humanity
so you've already declared that National
Emergency well in the practice you got a
bug on you oh thanks appreciate it so
you've already declared that National
Emergency practically speaking yes
too bad the Weather Channel wasn't
around to Shield Joe from the hunter
hurricane our very own peter Ducey
literally hopping a fence to get Biden's
uh first comments on his son's business
dealings
there's this testimony now where one of
your son's former business associates is
claiming that you were on speakerphone a
lot with them talking business is that
what whatever job business in England
and I know you'd have a lousy question
well what do you it's why is that a
lousy question thank you because it's
not true
thank you Mr President all right and it
looks like the wheels in the climate bus
are falling off Joe and kamala's beloved
electric vehicle companies filing for
bankruptcy despite all this cheerleading
we're going to end up owning the future
I think if you keep we keep doing what
we're doing we ought to be the single
most significant suppliers of electric
buses and vehicles in the world before
it's over right now we're running way
behind China but you guys are getting us
in the game
there you go judge welcome back good to
see you oh thank you it's good to be
back at the table to Rob some words from
my fellow-in-law and lefter you have a
delightful vacation glow oh thank you
I'm I appreciate that it's like you must
have had some fun yeah
later do you find it's funny that he is
on the Weather Channel after like I
don't know what is it like 20 phone
calls where apparently he was only
talking about the weather well you know
I think it's interesting because even
when I was in Europe I was reading about
Devin Archer and all of the stuff that
he started talking about in terms of
Joe's being aware not just being on a
speaker phone but being at dinners and
other things and it was rather stunning
to me that nobody was talking about it
uh in the mainstream media but not so
stunning
um but I think this whole thing with the
electric vehicles and protero the thing
that gets to me uh is Elizabeth granholm
okay so she's the secretary of energy
correct yeah and she's a woman who had
invested in proterra and aside from the
ethical issues of her promoting proterra
you've got Biden and Kamala Harris
specifically promoting a company that
the Secretary of Energy has a vested
interest in she exercises her stock
options and then sells her stock 12 days
later uh after the government has
invested millions of dollars I mean this
is about as a conflict as anything I've
seen and I think it broaches on the
issue of criminality
um and you have to say to yourself I
mean are these guys so corrupt that
they're willing to do it in your face
and then the company goes bust it's like
solyndra we put all our taxpayers
dollars in it and we make sure that the
taxpayers the last person to ever get
paid back but having said that I just
want to say one thing when I was
involved in there were all these little
cars and I said to one of the car
drivers I said you guys all Drive these
tiny cars are they electric cars and the
man says to me no no no I hate electric
cars they burn they go on fire all the
time now that's just a comment from the
you know a cab driver in Malta so
everybody knows that this electric
vehicle thing is nonsense you know I
heard that when Joe first got to the
Grand Canyon his first words were when
did they put my face up here yeah
because that
would yeah another wonder of the world
exactly he was about 800 miles south of
where that would have actually taken
place
um I I applaud Peter Ducey I imagine
that the president waved him over and
that's why the Secret Service let him
crawl over a fence I would say don't try
that at home or around the Secret
Service uh yeah unless you get the
explicit invitation but I think is
interesting is that now the White House
will say the president answered this
well no now because now you just
contradicted your press secretary who
contradicted herself so at some point
somebody is going to get a chance to
actually ask President Biden a question
where he's not surrounded by people
saying that's enough that's enough after
one little question like that so that's
not good enough on the climate thing
um Biden has spent an historic amount of
money to try to deal with climate change
and he has a 57 disapproval rating on
climate change especially from the left
they're not happy so the left has
created a monster that they can't
control and they're not done yet this is
an amazing thing I learned this week so
the trucking industry the manufacturers
of the trucking industry are facing some
really big regulations they're coming
down the pike January 1st they have to
go to this electric vehicle nonsense
okay maybe it's a worthwhile goal
however get this
the manufacturers are saying they're
doing it too too much too fast
for a diesel burning engine which is
pretty clean emissions are way down it
takes 15 minutes to fill up the truck
and that truck can then go 1200 miles
with these electric vehicles these
trucks take six to ten hours to charge
and they can go 250 miles amazing you
think that's not going to increase
prices for absolutely everybody because
everything that gets delivered is going
to take so much longer that is crazy uh
Jesse do you think it went on the
Weather Channel because he loves it when
Hunter makes it rain
he's never talking to his son about the
rain right yes
for anybody you know who owns The
Weather Channel this big Democrat donor
named Byron Allen he bought it for a
couple hundred million dollars because
he said that people are all going to die
unless we warn them that they're all
gonna die so this is just like the
safest possible space that he could
possibly go and she asks him when are
you going to declare a climate emergency
is that on as Jay was there kjp would
say is that's not top of mind no one is
out there clamoring when are you gonna
declare a climate emergency and his
answer was gobbledygook he goes we spent
300 billion dollars on a climate control
facility I would love to see this
facility what is it it's going to
control the climate he doesn't know what
he's talking about and then he just
basically walls off the entire million
Acres around the Grand Canyon for
Uranium mining so now we're completely
dependent on uranium from the Russians
and the kazakhstanes to countries that
just happened to pay his son a lot of
money and give them a poor Porsche the
EV bus deal is a pump and dump scheme
you had Grand Home you had Al Gore you
had Soros all pour money into this
stupid electric bus company and the
buses never worked they broke down all
over the country a lot of them caught
fire and then now it's a penny stock so
there needs to be an investigation there
how are you going to say I never talked
to them about business you were at a
dinner with a barisma executive for an
hour okay what'd you talk about that did
you talk about the weather for an hour
Joe Biden or how about they have a
stationary from the vice president
thanking Devin Archer for going into
business with your son okay so you're
going into business with myself you
don't know what the business is or how
about the voicemail oh yeah I read the
New York Times article about the
business that you're dealing with China
you're in the clear give me a call
come on Jessica come on
Jessica I don't even know what that
means come on you know what it means
well um
can I go yeah okay great oh of course
um if I want to talk about climate
change I'm gonna go on the Weather
Channel to talk about climate change it
seems like a pretty obvious
not just me I mean anyone like if
Republicans cared about climate change
then they should also go on the Weather
Channel to talk about climate change
now to Devon Archer so the testimony and
he wasn't under oath but he still wasn't
allowed to lie to them
um it was terrible for the Republicans
Jim Comer didn't even show up to think
well let's use real words then instead
of laughing or saying come on he was
asked if someone concluded from the 1023
form that you all think is so important
that Joe Biden was bribed would you
disagree with that yeah I would Devin
Archer said that what does he know about
that yeah well then he said he doesn't
matter then Devin Archer is either the
Crux of the puzzle that shows that this
is a mob family or he doesn't matter no
he said that Victor middle of it if he's
in the middle of a dinner then it
matters if it's something that he's not
there then it doesn't matter okay
Victor shokin was not good for barisma
as I've been telling you as has been
widely reported as the entire Western
World why because he wasn't
investigating
he was seizing their cars then what was
he doing what was showing I'm so glad
that you're back okay hold on one second
that's not good
did Hunter ever ask Joe to take any
official actions Devin Archer he did not
know thank you talk on the phone every
day
calls which are 20 calls over the course
of a decade if it weren't just the
weather he said they did talk about
family
did you see the interview yeah we talked
about the weather you guys will say
anything that's what he said there's a
new oversight menu uh menu memo that's
out today which again does not explain
what services were provided exactly
it didn't have any services
I should have said this last week the
IMF which you said we run stands for the
international
rich people the IMF it's our Rich guys
trying to get the prosecutor away from a
company that we want to do business with
quiet on my boat well it's over yeah I
think we should move on I think we
solved one of the world's most pressing
Problems by yelling you know it's an
underrated art just yell that's all you
got to do I want to Brian Kilmeade I
want you to do me a favor I want you to
click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now